[Music]
in too competitive news submitted by
goat Tings oh yeah I like gold
- girls wound up in the hospital after
doing a squat challenge what's that
so he's two girls from China uh one of
them is a 19 year old she said that she
decided to do a squat challenge with her
friend and so they set up a FaceTime
call and they just started doing squat
they are compared and they were both so
competitive that they wouldn't stop and
one of the girls said that she thinks
that they might have done over a
thousand squad yeah the time they
finally decided to stop and they don't
tell me which one one that's a [ __ ] but
the next day she said that she couldn't
really walk and she was like hey you
know that's normal I'm just sore and did
Sony just [ __ ] do squats out of
nowhere like they don't even work out
every day finding it better just like
bucket we need to lose weight squat
challenge
well they don't report the backstory on
the squat I like to hope that it was
that she thought that was normal and
then the next day her legs were still
sore but she went to work as usual and
then she didn't realize how serious the
situation was until the morning of the
third day when she woke up and she was
unable to bend at the knees so she's
somehow back to the restroom and she
went to go pee and she noticed that her
urine was a color of black team oh
that's internal bleeding she learned
from the army that that's a sign of
serious problems in your body and so she
was rushed to the hospital where they
diagnosed her with rhabdo Ulysses sorry
I tortured that but it's a
life-threatening condition that's caused
by the death of muscle fibers and so
they released their contents into the
bloodstream and that could lead to
life-threatening complication like renal
failure and so all that stuff gets
concentrated in the urine that's just
you can do too many squats and you die
you don't that's your cause of death too
many squats it was the death of muscle
fibers yeah cuz she went too hard yeah
so like so but how what's the point
where they normally die there
no like actual like threshold this is
how trained you are like if you never
ran and if you just ran like a triple
marathon you probably die too just like
if you're not like a free diver and you
just try to hold your breath for six
minutes you probably die if they were
trained up to that point like if you've
been practicing holding your breath for
a minute and then two minutes in three
minutes they do Pikul freedive and hold
your breath for five minutes I think for
them they probably never did it so a
thousand squats is a lot to them but to
someone that squats all the time it
might not even be that much didn't even
know that your muscle fibers could die
dude I didn't know you could die from
that drink you too much water but that
happened to some chick a couple years
ago yeah water poisoning yeah so then
she ended up calling her friend and then
it turns out that the friend also had to
be admitted to the hospital so putting
the hospital together yes I had one
photo holy that's what's crazy by a
zillion I shouldn't have done no
thousand squats
I love how colorful the hospital is
maybe it's her personal that looks like
a hospital bed look at that it looks
comfortable I'm either personal blanket
oh yeah cuz some people take their own
blankets and pillows to the husband
that's so comfortable pie smells like
mothballs oh yeah yeah is she gonna be
okay yes it's gonna be okay but they are
reporting that that separately how do
you even cure that you just relax all
from that point yeah that I don't know
I've known a couple athletes that have
reached that point and they're extremely
well trained athletes but it [ __ ] they
still went past their threshold and you
can still get it's a it's a result of
overtraining do the fibers grow back
yeah they recover just at that point
like let's say so your body burns
glucose for energy it gets to a point
where like you already burned all the
vertical or ik reserves and now that
you're still training so it still needs
to get energy from somewhere so it's
nice breaking down like your muscles and
stuff so that's where muscle fibers died
is that after it burns all the glucose
it goes to your Hill starting to be in
the way at it yeah but then if you start
doing like in high amounts than that
this is what happens yeah they're saying
that it's the breakdown of muscle tissue
that releases a damaging protein to the
blood and the treatment as early
treatment with aggressive fluid
replacement reduces the risk of kidney
damaged so it's like IV fluids Jude was
there anything about cocaine mentioned
here
I know [ __ ] yeah did I drink water
that's a lot
maybe big bro hundred maybe and then
they probably fasted too while they were
doing this yeah lose weight girl and get
a but you gotta lose weight and get a
button you think they gotta but the next
morning though all their muscle fibers
died but they got a bad heart perfect
heart shape that I think that ass got
smaller from getting burnt down oh it's
late it you know um I don't know if you
guys feel this but when you watch a
movie and like you see some guy getting
his arm chopped off like your arm just
feels weak and you're just like oh my
arm
yeah so by reading this story my entire
body cuz I actually worked out be proud
of me I did two workouts in one day you
got muscle fatigue no no no so I'm
really sore all over I will Saurus [ __ ]
we're reading this story did two
workouts on one day yeah it's insane
I did its curls and cats know I did a
barre class okay are you being sarcastic
yeah man I've done aerial yoga what the
[ __ ] is that it was so much fun I need
to try it's like my little mermaid yoga
what's Barre class is it's hard right so
far it's like bad bar is dance Pilates
yoga and belly well you have that bar
that you put on and no no no no it's
like okay yeah and then it's just a lot
of bodyweight stuff that's dope in an
area yoga it's like with the silks yeah
and then like my arms are sore as [ __ ]
the other hold on and it was really the
silk gave you mate just sore yeah oh
you're holding up your body weight like
a Cirque show I thought she was holding
a scarf in her arms that tired
relax and work out by I heard it's
really hard it was really hard get back
to your point I did I already said my
point I said she can't see you felt it
yeah I just feel extra likes or even
though I'm sorry she's like maybe
happening to me I'm like [ __ ] am I
getting this like phantom pain or some
[ __ ] it's called empathy pain pain pain
what's also you could be what Nicky has
which is we you empath what's not highly
sensitive people
yes highly sensitive people well no no
also to the thing where you think that
everything's gonna kill you that's Nicky
really I don't see you like that yeah
cuz I I talk myself out of it I have
like oh I have an emotional side in a
logical side and the logic ones as long
as like hey you don't need this let's
calm down then let's walk it through an
emotional sides like no I'm gonna die
and then like to the public I'm like no
I got the logic and I got a handle I'll
calm her down like recently she thought
she was gonna because she swallowed a
little bit of glass yeah well well which
makes sense there's a lot of reddit
story you swallow ankle I didn't eat it
so my I don't think she ever meet okay
so like the Tupperware I have all the
glasses stacked because it's like Last
Supper where and then I guess one
shipped off into the other one and so
when I put food into that - I I think
there was small there's ax okay little
slivers yeah it's like eating sand but
like I was reading about people that
smell [ __ ] that emotional side of you
that's [ __ ] you over because that's
when you go and research this [ __ ] yeah
and then that's when you a minute hypes
it all up yeah damn I think I'm never
gonna die that's crazy you know research
no no it really shows he's not gonna die
though like if I got mud water my mouth
I'm my adult extra mineral-y super
optimist very positive yeah see I used
to be like that and then I got so many
random things like when we went to
Mexico when I got the like hookworm in
my foot like what
who gets Huck who are and what's
hookworm it's like you can get it from
walking barefoot in like certain
countries and that goes in your foot and
she had to get like a medication to get
rid of it is that like ringworm kind of
yeah
it's not like a real worm it's like a
fungus or whatever yeah then to Lily
about it either Tulum or Costa Rica I
know they were back to back so I don't I
don't know exactly which and I was
barefoot on both of those but yeah like
I didn't think about any of that I'm
like living my carefree life and then I
go get back and I have hookworm and then
I go to the dermatologist no like you
didn't get this here in America and I
was like no I think I was traveling and
they're like we've never even seen this
and had to go to there and then they had
to look it up and they're like yeah we
think it is that a book see it in I'm a
hypochondriac but then I'm right a lot
of time dude you're dude you know how
many people told this [ __ ] that she
wasn't losing weight because she's not
burning enough calories or whatever and
she's like no you understand like I'm
not even eating that much like I've been
working out like all the [ __ ] and then
she's like the her obsessive [ __ ]
crazy mind there's something going on in
there and this thing that that she has
been diagnosed with now Columbia and
it's like a gut health thing that Zebo
SIBO and it's a gut hope thing that
makes her blown out if she has certain
foods because there's a secret kind of
thing where like you like the law of
attraction or whatever how you just like
putting it out there even though you
don't want it it's a good take a road
first secret cuz I'm like living my life
and then I get some [ __ ] and I'm like oh
no is this this and then I look it up
and I'm like oh [ __ ] I maybe have this
and then they're like yeah she started
doing this SIBO diet and she got rid of
all of her bloat in like six weeks yes
you're not gassing in the stomach
anymore um I was never gassy I think
that was the problem is that later
top-floor it ever came out yeah like no
the review so you just feel blow yeah
you tryna fart but it doesn't come out
yeah and then never she would see bloat
there's crazy low like I was like six
months pregnant looking that just means
that you're good at deduction that's all
it is
she's very good at fear and [ __ ] oh yeah
right so you balance it out because
you're the emotional side is like oh
[ __ ]
I gotta handle this now yeah whereas
like someone like maybe bar will be like
ah
cancer schmancer you know you just wait
until it's like oh [ __ ] and I got to
take it seriously
yeah because it's like the emotional
sides like I'm gonna die and then this
was like wait let's figure it out and
then you actually go into the science of
yeah versus like maybe someone going hey
I think it's an evil spirit and you're
like oh really
well [ __ ] I better go do my
[ __ ] Hail Mary's thank you oh I
just like looked up symptoms and then
looked at weather because it could
possibly do yeah
WebMD and like they have some gnarly
ones where I'm like okay I don't think
it's that let's not go to the crazy one
but it could be this sometimes I've had
ones that are like it could be a heart
attack or it could be this really benign
thing that nothing happens
oh that chest yeah the custom
costochondritis if you remember that I
talked about it before I go watch that
video but yeah it's like they have the
same exact symptoms so I'm like I better
go and then they're like they did the
EKG think and then they're like no you
have to dang I suppose you could line up
every single person who told you you
weren't burn enough calories whatever in
a room and then show them you're like I
[ __ ] had SIBO you [ __ ] know
nothing you know nothing Jon Snow people
fakes
yeah baby that's all they think
everyone's yeah everyone's a [ __ ] ex
runs in eggs back on other people's
bodies even though they don't [ __ ]
all yeah
[Music]